[Musique]
je m'appelle marie young hurel je suis
écrivain ou faut-il dire écrivaine au
foot y lire auteurs redire aux tris
l'arn est en plein dans le débat actuel
pour la jeunesse essentiellement mais
pas que parce qu en fait j'écris depuis
30 ans et se trouve que mes lecteurs ont
grandi avec moi je suis aussi un auteur
assez scolarisés donc ça fait que le
plus souvent on m'a rencontrée sur son
parcours je suis un auteur réaliste mais
j'ai écrit des contes de fées
à part le fait qu'on n'a toujours pas
trouvé non pour simplifier tout va bien
ce qui prouve que la langue française
est effectivement machiste mais enfin
voila je vais pas réécrire l'histoire
comme je l'expliqué jean moi j'ai grandi
dans un univers où le masculin l'emporté
je me suis démerdé voilà et j'ai fini
par l'emporter aussi originaire manche
une petite vite atteint voilà j'ai
grandi dans la bd est un temps peut pas
dire que ce soit très sexuée quand j'ai
commencé à écrire pour les ados en fait
j'ai pris un jeu pour m'identifier et
j'ai pris un jus masculin
désolé j'aime le verlan j'aime largo
j'aime les gros gros parce que ils sont
tous dans le dictionnaire c'est que ce
que j'ai expliqué aux enfants vous savez
si vous regardez de bordel c'est
dans le larousse
donc moi j'aime tous les maux et quand
je parle aux enfants je fais ce geste
d'éventail ça veut dire qu'on a droit à
tout regarder le mot écrire vous
visualisez de daria quoi il ya cris et à
rire il ya ce mook connaissent les
cruciverbistes here i re c'est la colère
donc tu as toutes les émotions humaines
c'est que dans la langue française elle
est mathiot mais avec ce mot là a fait
fort
je me suis interrogé sur les écrivains
femmes du passé et j'ai vu dans
l'ensemble elle n'avait pas d'enfant et
est-ce que ça a un sens est ce que ça
veut dire que la vie normale d'une femme
épouse et mère ça ne peut pas aller
vraiment avec une vie d'artiste
mon père me l'a dit au moment où je me
suis marié il me l'a écrit j'ai ça
allait être il m'a dit que dans son
hostilité modéré à mon mariage
il y avait cette peur que je me contente
d'une vie normale de femmes
quand on est
jeune maman quand on est un combat des
crises et du temps volé d'écrire
[Musique]